e
it's good enough it being 9:05 and uh us
having an absence of the chair right now
uh as Vice chair I'm going to call the
capital project overview committee
meeting to
order
um we don't take attendance on this do
we no out loud all then I'm just going
to move to item number one which was the
acceptance of minutes of the January 26
meeting I'd move uh acceptance of the
minutes motion has been
made is there a
second we have it made and
seconded I'll do a Voice vote all in
favor say I opposed motion
carries two extensions
got that Mr cler yeah thank you item two
old business
none item three new business
none item four miscellaneous
none this is why I'm in charge this is
where this is how we roll okay item
c2401 from the Department of
administrative services
quarterly Capital project report for
quarter ending December 17th I'm sorry
December 31st
2023 and who's going to uh lead on that
information Mr sh so typically the
committee doesn't have anybody speak to
this quar report um so it's just
informational and if there's any
questions you can give them to me and
then I can follow up with the Department
fabulous that's why I'm on a roll
representative Wier sorry to slow it
down oh okay I'm comparing
24004 to
24001 and I'm looking at projects that
have been going on forever like the
dairy London Dairy 193 exit
4A project
13065 and I noted it in the February it
was like at
59,000 then it goes to 64,000 in the in
the latest one that's quite a change as
well as the one that went from 33 to 36
the
1306b
1365b so it's I'm wondering about if
that's going to be typical of all the
projects and if we're going to be able
to afford to are those just would those
just be quarterly
expenditures so the agencies provide
information to administrative Services
as it relates to the activity on the
projects so there may be update on the
expenses that they've incurred from from
one quarter to the next the
Appropriations don't change though so
the projects have been appropriated X
dollar through a capital project House
Bill 25 or through a in Do's example
through the budget um what they show you
typically is what they encumber and what
they've expended and what a balance
forward is in the
report but I can get more detail if you
would like represent wer on those couple
projects it seemed like that was the
appropriation and those projects have
been going on forever
so so in the quarterly report the
appropriation the original appropriation
goes away after the first quarter so the
the number isn't carried forward in this
report that's something that the
department of administrative Services I
have talked about um when the first year
of the capital budget is included you'll
see the appropriation amount but after
that they just show you what's remaining
and then what they've expended so keeps
decreasing you spend a couple of bucks
to mail me all this stuff so I thought I
should look it over a little bit thank
you but I can certainly get answers to
any specific questions I can talk with
you offline if you'd like
y all right then in as regards to that I
guess we are also covering at the same
time the cap
244 Department of administrative
Services quarterly Capital project for
March 31st
2024 cover them both at the same time
any other
questions moving on to capap
24002 Department of Natural and cultural
re
resources update regarding the Canon
Mountain Tramway capital projects dated
April 8th
2024 once again this is
informational any questions or do does
like to ah
okay you're up then good morning
everybody uh Thea Stewart commissioner
of the Department of Natural and
cultural
resources and the tram uh represents
both the natural and the cultural part
of our agency um I'm going to speak for
a second and then I brought people who
are way smarter about the technical
aspects of this really big project um
but I'd like to just start by saying
this is uh we're now in year four of of
talking about the future of the tram um
and we've we've landed at um what we
thought was a successful um amount of 18
million um and went out to bid and that
was not enough which is a story you've
heard many times I think uh in this room
um and so we we need to sort of go back
to our corners and and figure out what
to do to move this forward um assuming
the state of New Hampshire would like to
see the tram um reinstated in and in
place for the next 40 years um the
legislative uh decisionmakers in 1978 79
decided to invest in the tram um and now
it's your turn to deliberate on this um
iconic New Hampshire experience um and
before I I turn it over or let you ask
specific questions um it's really
important to the uh the makeup of the
state park system as you um all know the
state park system in New Hampshire is
operationally self-funded which is a
unique way for any state to run their
state parks and it works really well for
us um we are charged by RSA to run like
a business and the tram is one of our
largest uh single funders of our Park
system uh and so for us um not only is
it a wonderful experience to offer at
frankone not State Park but it's really
important to um to provide that funding
to state parks that don't raise enough
money to self- sustain um and so with
that you all have the letter that I that
I drafted to summarize uh the process um
I'll be quiet I'll entertain questions
and call up um uh phone a friend as
guys I'm sorry first off any questions
representative wer thank you Mr chair I
say that it it says $1.8 million a year
in Revenue so what does it cost to ride
when was the last time it was
increased uh and obviously if it's if
it's been 40 years since we invested
that money of of 20 million and and uh
now or less than that and now it's paid
for itself and more so can we go up in
the in the ride price and you know so
that it'll pay for itself again thank
you great question I'll turn to Brian
Wilson who's our Park
director um so um it's been about uh a
little over a year since the last
incremental change uh for the tram ride
it's about uh $20 per person uh for for
a roundtrip and um it is the the fee is
set as part of our uh within our fee
package within the state park system uh
that would uh be a recommendation that
comes forward through the commissioner
uh to the fiscal committee so uh in our
last Fe
um update we opted to not increase uh
the rate or to propose an increase to
the rate um and um there was a few other
areas within the fee uh package as well
too like the the The Flume Gorge uh
relative to frankonia notch where we we
rates that that said representative um I
I think I think if we are confident that
we're going to have resources to put a
shiny new tram in in in its place and
have a big ribbon cutting and uh and a
hoopla I think that would be the time to
re-evaluate the the ticket prices and uh
and per RSA we are supposed to be in
line with with the market value and I
think we would have room to tick it up a
bit if I might Senator reeners please uh
good morning thanks for being here um
quick question 1.8 million in Revenue
profitability um that fluctuates really
year to year depending on what uh some
of the costs that are going into the
maintenance but generally relative it uh
generates uh a net revenue of over a
you any other
questions uh so the only one I have is I
know that so we have the state
legislature we've already authorized $18
million on this and your first and only
bid came in at 33.3
million so it's up to us to uh looking
for capital budget request of an
additional $15 million
correct okay any other information
us um short of additional funding we as
the commissioner said we we are kind of
back at the uh kind of square one back
at the drawing board we are uh working
with uh the lyt companies that we have
have worked with and that we're looking
at this particular project uh to examine
some Alternatives I I I guess I'll say
in in sort of a soft estimate costs um
the this this process that we went
through uh for the design uh build um
resulted in the outcome that we got with
which was just one bid and we were
hopeful to receive more than one uh the
other manufacturer and uh lift provider
had uh instead of submitting a bid to us
provided us a memo with uh some you know
the the reasons why they didn't submit a
bit and some questions and some concerns
about our the process that we went about
so we're kind of taking that information
and and hoping to kind of give this give
this another go uh our concern
really lies in um it it'll take us some
considerable time probably upwards of
another year I think to um come out of
the other end of another bidding process
um so um with our the recent um
submission of our agency's uh capital
budget request we wanted to make sure
that that U additional $15 million was
was put out there uh for for everyone's
awareness um because we won't know
whether 18 is going to really work or
not uh for for for some time here now um
so it's it's it was uh disappointing to
say the least for us to kind of go
through the whole process over the last
year and a half to come out with that
outcome but we're not we're sharpening
trying I'm sorry Senator n did you have
yeah thank you it may be in the in the
letter and I missed it um how many
writers per year I'm coming up with
about 990,000 based on the number
numbers you've
shared is that
accurate um we we do I I'll will have to
I can provide that information we do
keep keep detailed uh attendance records
uh so I'd have to get that for you okay
I'm having fun with math and thinking
well you know if you add $5 to the
ticket price on that number of riders
know that's an extra 450,000 a year
assuming there's no decline in writers
ship and maybe we can find a way to
finance out of future revenues or
something like that okay thank
you representative evil thank you thank
you Mr chair so um at some point you
really start to lose functionality I
guess of the tram and it sounds like
we're rapidly approaching that point and
I mean could you just talk a little bit
about stop Gap measures how much longer
they're likely to work just an overall
picture thanks uh no problem I'll turn
that over to Brian too but uh we do
inspect it
daily uh safety
first um yeah we've been uh essentially
put on notice from the the the
manufacturer that uh certain components
are you know ex uh approaching their end
of life and because of uh it being a
over 40-year-old system uh some of those
parts are not going to be replaceable or
very easily replaceable uh so uh
essentially it has been determined that
it is you know at the at the end of its
life um we recently had a thirdparty
engineering firm come through uh to
provide uh uh an in-depth assessment of
it and and gave us essentially a clean
bill of health uh through uh the rest of
the summer and this next uh Winter Ski
season um that said you know we we also
have heard from the manufacturer that
you know this system isn't something
that um that can just continue to to to
operate without some plan of you know
what the next phase is whether that's
decommissioning or um you know a
construction of of of a new system uh so
um we would like to be able to plan for
that and and phase any construction in
to the best of our ability within our
operation to help mitigate any loss of
Revenue uh to to the greatest extent as
well too so that's that's really
important for us to have uh any downtime
be minimized to the to to to the
greatest
extent follow I I remember some
discussion about this this was not
funding um it it may have been eligible
by eligibility standards but we were we
at this point I would like to turn the
meeting back over to Chairman mononi
thank
you thank you and I apologize for my
tardiness um and I would like to catch
up on this
conversation um is there more to the
presentation that questions from from
the committee we're just answering
questions right now so and so and I
apologize for being late I honestly do
so if if I understand correctly the
amount of funds that are needed now to
move forward with the project we're at
about halfway with that uh we're looking
at potentially 15 million
additional
dollars okay all right no no further
questions yes please it's it's nearly a
doubling but I think the problem is
there's a limited number of trams and a
very limited number of people that build
them I don't know how many comp
companies there are but they kind of
have a monopoly here and we're kind of
stuck with it but it is a it is a uh
Revenue generat we can't Overlook that
and uh you know and if things go well
and we should be able to pay for it
within a few years and even have money
to spare I'm in favor of of spending
whatever it is to take care of this is
probably the only one of the few trams
in New England thank you thank you R wer
yes please repr so just a followup
um I understand you're directed not to
ask for ARA funds and the LBA may be
able to assist maybe not my
understanding is there's a reasonable
trunch of money left at the moment that
still has not been obligated and needs
to be obligated or we lose it um do we
know how much money that is and has
anyone gone back to make a second
ask thank you um I do not know how much
more money there is we report regularly
to the Gopher team um and they have they
have not been in a position to tell us
how much money there is I know that
they're getting requests
hourly um and so you know
if if that's an option I think that
commissioner Caswell would need to be
talked
to about this R Wilder uh we ran into
this Opera funding on another project if
the construction isn't finished by the
end of 2026 you can't ask for the money
and obviously this won't qualify on
those grounds so I don't think we should
pursue that because there's no way this
is going to be finished by the end of
2026 so especially when we're spending
all this time getting the bid thank you
thank you Senator gray uh that's not
necessary L true from what I hear okay
uh like the Strafford County nursing
home what they were going to do is pay
for a particular portion of that and
that was the foundation and the
engineering work that needed to happen
before so again the this project could
be broken up into smaller pieces and
then those smaller pieces but again you
know there's a lot of people out there
looking for those dollars so I don't
offer you much hope right now
thank thank you sandor um I just I'd
like to add one and then a comment on a
subject matter that's coming afterwards
in the our next meeting uh I was just in
uh New Mexico with my family graduation
couple three weeks ago Albuquerque and
we're right next to the Sandia Mountains
and I'm sure you folks are
familiar um that they have the largest
tram uh in uh North America there that
was just refurbished
and I don't think I got a family member
on that for the ride up to the top up to
10,000 ft for less than than $40 a
person if I remember right uh can you
just refresh my mind what sort of money
in the summer we charge per person to go
up Canon Mountain so I I answered that
before you came in but I uh I want to
update theod it's
$28 um is is the current uh emission
price and we in our last fee um uh fee
package proposal we opted to not uh
recommend an increase to that at at this
time uh although we do think that
there's additional um um ability to
increase that with with a new and
refreshed uh model uh and again most of
our visitation uh is is really happening
during the the the spring summer fall
months uh so that's that's where we
really see our our Revenue Peak for it's
it's really the summer visitation
um so I think that there is some options
there to um help either increase the
revenue for uh the park fund or in the
past I believe also a portion of uh the
costs attributed with Capital
Improvements to the tram have have been
bonded uh with a uh stipulation that uh
that is paid is paid for in part through
the revenues that have come in as well
too so thank you I appreciate those
comments um I also have weekends with
the family and friends and one of the
people I work with from Storyland and
their admission rate for a day is $75
skiing is1 $200 a day um I think you
need to aggressively look at what that
pricing is going to be from this one
person's point of view this is a massive
amount of money for something and we
shouldn't be thinking shortterm we
should be thinking long term I apologize
for the would you believe uh my my
second for the commissioner and thank
you again for being here and I don't
know you'll be here later so I just want
to comment appreciate your work on the
uh State Park Properties with the
amateur radio I think we're getting
close it might need a little push from
you um and lastly I believe we have an
item in here that we're coming up to
about the selling of a piece of land
that was deemed by your group as not
being essential
um it's it's in here that would be for
long range the next meeting yes yeah
that's that's what I meant I wasn't
looking for your comment but I did have
a conversation with your department
about a parcel in oopy that's connected
to the uh to the boat ramp that leads to
Opie Lake and the town of uh the town of
Opie or the state police now have posted
the highway out front where overflow
parking goes I would love to engage in a
conversation a serious conversation
about taking some of that excess
property for fish and game back there so
if we could talk about that at another
time perhaps we can talk about that um
at Bobby
Sue's Madam I I totally agree it's our
local it's our local ice cream stance
thank you um any further questions
representative I just had one comment
about the Tramway yes so next week the
governor's capital budget hearings are
being held um as the commissioner stated
this is on their number one request um
is going to be heard next week so
yourself and and um Senator inis will
probably be at that meeting just so you
know in case you have further questions
or you want to um put something out
there to be considered as that project
looks to be included in a capital budget
or not thank you I appreciate that uh
we'll move on to our last item thank you
uh thank you folks Department of Natural
and cultural resources uh Department of
Environmental Service uh status report
welcome good
morning thank you I always get confused
red to me should be not on not on but so
uh good morning I'm Bob Scott
commissioner for the Department of
Environmental Services I have with me uh
assistant commissioner uh Adam kpo and
behind me someplace there he is uh is a
Phil Trowbridge who runs our lrm section
which is Alter alteration of terrain
which is storm water uh Wetlands
Shoreland and septic I think that's all
the that's enough he says
yeah so so real quickly uh so um I just
want to reiterate uh from my office that
uh e permitting getting getting our uh
we do a lot of Permitting in the uh the
department uh getting those online
available to the public
uh is not only essential for the
efficiency for for the practitioners out
there who who use our uh Permitting
Services uh and just our uh our data for
environmental data uh but also for the
Department itself so that's that's
important uh you have our um April uh
report obviously uh We've continued to
make progress uh beyond that report uh
as we should uh with things like uh
online forms as I mentioned electronic
payment um and digitizing of historical
records those are some of the highlights
uh I uh our assistant commissioner is
heading this up along with Mr trobridge
for the lrm uh portion of this uh and uh
be happy to pass it to him and obviously
we're here to answer really answer any
of your
questions thank you as always great uh
great tea up from the commissioner um so
as he mentioned in April we provided
some written updates uh to the committee
and you know historically we've had to
process our permits by paper um even up
until this La the last few years um so
this the money that was appropriated to
these projects is really bringing us
into the 21st century and and doing a
lot for our constituents our customers
um so the the goal is to bring 118 forms
and
lrm uh up onto the website for E filing
and E permitting um so folks can uh file
from their couch if they would they
would like to do so um you know last
week was a really big milestone in this
process we were able to upload um
various applications all of our
Shoreland forms are online with payment
and uh various other forms are are
online as well and we're going to be
working vigorously over the next uh
several years but but certainly next few
months to get uh our wet a bunch of
wetlands forms up and and various other
forms onto the website um so that's
that's the update on the eiling piece um
digitization of subsurface records uh we
were given $2 million to uh or we put $2
million out to records Force to process
our historical records for subsurface
files uh those are AC septic system
files between 1967 to present day
um and phase one we're we're
anticipating that to be completed in
April of
2025 um that in phase one that really
encompasses the our oldest files that's
1967 to 1986 and and that that's
probably our our I would say it's one of
our most helpful initiatives currently
uh for folks to be able to go in online
and figure out um for a piece of
property maybe they're buying you know
what the history of that that uh septic
system is and and all the information
around it currently they're housed in
various physical locations across the
department and so it really takes I want
to call it an act of Congress but it it
takes someone coming in or or calling to
initiate the process of finding it and
we have actual actual physical cards to
go and figure out where it's located
within the building so this that'll be a
really uh helpful initiative and we've
already got uh we're able to get
14,000 files uh digital files online so
that's that's great um and then for
subsurface designers and installers
we're working to allow those folks to
renew their credentials by uh December
of 2024 we anticipate to uh to have that
uh the ability for folks to renew those
up actually well before that I think
September is the time frame for that
project and so we're pretty good
progress on that um and so I I'll turn
it over to Phil he's the our subject
matter expert on on all of the the land
resources management projects uh to add
any Clarity or additional detail into
those
projects good morning Phil trobridge
manager of land resources um not much to
add on the presentation but I'll just
put some numbers on it uh for the our
Shor forms are now 100%
online um and our Wetlands forms were at
13% we anticipate being 100% by the end
of the summer so things are moving
really fast for us right now with
getting the forms online and so far the
adoption of these forms has been really
quick uh we've put a Complaint Form
online this is where people can um let
us know about suspected Wetlands
violation or something and now 80% of
our forms come in all 80% of the form
forms are submitted digitally so we we
expect that early adoption is going to
happen rapidly I guess I don't think we
can call ourselves early adopters but
you know we're uh we're getting these
things out there and they're being used
um I'd say the other other thing that is
often lost on this is the efficiency
gains that we're achieving with our
internal staff as a result of these
forms um the processing of the papers
faster not having physical checks to
handle having all the files in one place
so that as our staff are distributed
across different offices they can access
them and there's no uh waiting for you
know can I get that file from P's
questions um same thing for right to no
requests it's just a lot easier to do it
digitally uh and then on the subsurface
digitization project we had three places
where we had the files now we only have
two we've cleaned one out so um I'd say
we're we're starting to make real gains
and our our Mantra on this has been you
know want people to be able to to file
without a printer without a check and
without a stamp and we're we're getting
there thank you U thank you uh stbridge
um commissioner scottt you've assembled
a great team it's first time we've had
uh assistant kpo in the in the room
today and I appreciate that and to me uh
from coming from uh Public Works um this
has been money well spent and your eye
is on top of this and getting this this
information digitized is just phenomenal
for everyone uh getting Shoreland and
wetlands dragging them in from the weeds
and and getting this online this is
phenomenal for practitioners which I and
my family are so when these documents a
question for I don't know which
gentleman when these items are are
scanned and made digital form are we
then removing the old files getting rid
of those files
uh yes we are um we have a a QA step
that we go through U we get the we get
the files from records Force who's the
vendor but then we have three staff
inous three temporary staff who are
reviewing them making sure the
information is accurate uh and um and
then getting it into our database and
then those boxes are sent for
Destruction sounds good and so will once
the subsurface is taken care of will you
then start pulling the uh the short land
permits and Wetland permits and getting
those digitized also or can you get that
on a list we we have that on our list
and we we do a little bit of that when
we have downtime when the vendor is not
providing us information as fast as we
can we we put those staff towards
questions thank you I appreciate your
time the updates great and we'll see you
in a few months thank you thank you
was that our last item on our our last
item
okay I I have always said uh subsurface
has just has been on the ball and then
to find out that uh we're getting the
rest of the Departments I think it's
so we have um our next meeting will
start at 10 o'clock correct so we so we
have a little bit of a motion toj U
motion to adjourn just before you do
that the date of the next meeting will
that be at the call of the chair oh what
what would your suggestion be I'd say
call of the chair okay um reason being
since we didn't have any action items
today it'd be nice to encourage that to
happen full credit for how quickly this
meeting you did an amazing job rep s
items like nothing that's what we like
to hear all right so is there any other
business to
discuss good
morning
uh then U motion's been made in second
we're adjourned till our next uh meeting
which will be when there's subject
matter and in the call of the chair
thank you very good thank you and we